at the start of the movie A group of
archaeologists are exploring some
dangerous caves in Pennsylvania as they
Venture deeper they come across a large
mine which appears to be a big find this
sends them into a state of ecstasy and
they begin celebrating however little
did they know that they have actually
awoken some deadly beings in a matter of
seconds the researchers are attacked by
several flying creatures they are
brutally killed and devoured after this
the flying creatures escaped to the
outside world to find more human flesh
were then taken to a high school in
Montclair New Jersey where Ally Andrew a
deaf teenager endures cruel mockery from
a group of bullet for her hearing
impairment however she appears to be
unbothered and decides to walk all the
way home it is revealed that allies
hearing loss resulted from a car
accident 3 years ago which tragically
claimed the lives of her beloved
grandparents despite this adversity she
effectively communicates through sign
language lip reading and speaking in the
meantime rob a kind-hearted classmate
comes forward and offers to ACC company
Ally on her way home it is apparent that
the two have feelings for each other but
are too shy to admit it alli's parents
Hugh and Kelly are well aware of the
fact that she is always bulled by other
students they have tried every way to
protect her but all in vain the rest of
the family members include allies
maternal grandmother Lynn who is
struggling with lung cancer her younger
brother Jude and their lovely dog Otis
one night Ali is suddenly woken up from
her sleep and summoned to the living
room to her utter shock her entire
family is watching the TV in a worried
State all doors and windows appear to be
barred by plastic then the news reports
that a mysterious alien species is
causing Havoc across the United States
they are completely blind but can track
and kill humans even if a tiny noise is
made because of their dinosaur-like
appearance they have been labeled as
vesps the news report then shows videos
of various people who have fallen victim
to these creatures in one such video a
woman is nervously holding a sign which
says don't make noise in the background
her daughter's mouth has been taped shut
so that she doesn't scream at the the
end the news report concludes by saying
that the US has declared a state of
emergency so all the families should
stay indoors without making any noise
fearing that they might be in trouble
Ally suggests that they escape to the
countryside since it is quieter there
Hugh immediately agrees and so the
family starts packing after a while
their close neighbor Glenn also joins
them bringing guns along with him
elsewhere we are shown a gut-wrenching
Montage of the creatures destroying the
city in an underground Metro blood is
splattered everywhere along with several
dead bodies
the survivors have crammed inside the
train Carriage praying that the
creatures will go away just then a baby
starts crying much to everyone's horror
when his mother fails to calm him down
the rest of the passengers kick them out
of the carriage unfortunately this turns
out to be a fatal decision as in the
blank of an eye the Mother Sun Duo is
swarmed by the creatures on the other
hand as the Andrews family stop at a gas
station to refuel a shady looking man
suddenly shows up and holds Ally at
gunpoint he demands that the family give
up their car so that he can escape the
city Hugh fearful that his daughter
might get hurt almost hands in the keys
but right then Glenn shows up and shoots
the man in the foot after this the
family takes his gun and leaves him to
die alone however they are not able to
reach far as a massive traffic jam has
blocked all the highways it turns out
all the people in the city are trying to
head to the countryside Glen who seems
to know his way around proposes that
they take a detour he then leads them
through a road that is completely
isolated suddenly a herd of fleeing
deers jump out of the woods Blen swerves
his car violently in order to avoid
Collision but ends up tumbling down the
barrier the Andrew's family witness all
this and frantically rush to help him to
their relief he is alive but trapped
inside the car time is running out and
Ally tries calling for help but there is
no signal in the area even Hugh is
unable to open the car's door with a
wrench when nothing works Glenn requests
that the Andrews leave without him he
calls himself dead weight and mentions
that he is only going to slow him down
he refuses the idea instantly but after
a lot of convincing he reluctantly
agrees he then leaves with his family
but promises to come back with help
after a while they reach their car and
prepare to leave but just then Otis
starts barking Panic ensues and the
vesps immediately swarm the car when
Glenn realizes what's going on he fires
some shots in the air and lur the
creatures towards him unfortunately the
sacrifice goes into vain as Otis keeps
on barking Hugh tries his best to shut
him up but when nothing works he
reluctantly throws his beloved dog out
of the car seemingly to his is death
realizing that the car will only attract
the vesps the Andrews make the tough
call to leave it behind Hugh then sets
the car on fire to divert the attention
of the Relentless vesps after this the
family starts walking through the woods
hoping that they can find a safe place
to take shelter as they walk for hours
Lynn's coughing becomes worse causing
concern for the entire family by evening
they stumble upon a house nestled in the
woods it is enclosed by a tall fence and
a locked gate unfortunately their
arrival attracts the attention of the
vesps and at the same same time the
homeowner also comes out due to the
isolated location of the house she is
unaware of the creatures so she rushes
outside screaming at The Intruders while
brandishing a gun sadly she is
immediately surrounded and torn apart by
the vesps the Andrews watch all this go
down in horror knowing that they have
inadvertently killed an innocent woman
nonetheless he remains focused and looks
for a way inside the property after a
bit of searching he finds a small tunnel
and uses it to get inside the compound
then he operates the wood chipper
machine and lurs all the asps towards
him the plan works and the evil
creatures are mercilessly shredded to
Pieces however during the commotion
Kelly is bitten in the leg in the next
scene the family enters the house and
makes themselves comfortable allly
somehow connects to Rob via video call
and learns that his parents have been
killed by the creatures worried she asks
him to join him in the countryside but
before he can respond the call
disconnects the next day Lynn carefully
examines Kelly's wound and discovers
signs of infection hence he makes the
tough decision to venture into the city
in search of antibiotics Ally also joins
him despite all the family members
urging her to stay after scavening
through the deserted City they finally
come across a store and head inside Hugh
starts Gathering the supplies but right
then Ally accidentally makes some noise
and attracts the vesps things are about
to take a turn for the worse but
fortunately H manages to turn on the
fire sprinklers just in time this
distracts the deadly creatures for a
while allowing the father daughter Duo
to escape however once they reach
outside they are confronted by a
menacing looking revered who has
apparently cut his tongue it is revealed
that he is the leader of a notorious
cult group that is Infamous for killing
non-believers the Reverend signals them
to join him but he straight out refuses
and walks away with his daughter they
safely reach home and administer the
antibiotics on Kelly making her feel
better unfortunately that evening the
Reverend and his followers show up
outside the house and demand that Hugh
join their cult when the latter refuses
the Reverend hisses in a creepy way and
then displays a note note which reads
the girl as fertile seeing this an
enraged Hugh brings out his gun and
threatens the cult members to leave the
Reverend is sure that Hugh is not going
to pull the trigger as it will attract
the vesps but nonetheless he leaves them
be at least for the time being when the
clock strikes 12 the Andrews are woken
up by loud noises coming from outside
Hugh quickly grabs his gun and checks
the front door where he sees a
frightened little girl he suspects that
it's a trap and decides to send her away
but Kelly goes against his orders and
lets the girl in the family then
interrogates the girl on how she ended
up here but she doesn't speak just then
Hugh checks her mouth and discovers that
she doesn't have a tongue to make
matters worse her body has been strapped
with several mobile phones which are
like time bombs at this point the next
second the mobile phones start ringing
at once sending the family into a
complete state of frenzy this attracts
the creatures as expected and they start
breaking through the windows Hugh dumps
all the funds inside the water but the
damage has already been done on the
other hand the cult members have already
entered the house through the basement
they first knock Kelly out and then
abduct Ally seeing this the courageous
grandmother Lynn runs after the cult
members and grabs two of them she then
screams at the top of her lungs and
attracts the vesps in no time the deadly
creatures arrive and tear the two men
apart and fortunately Lynn is also
shredded to Pieces when the commotion
finally ends Hugh arrives at the scene
but it's too late as the Reverend has
already left with his daughter just when
it appears as if all hope is lost it
starts raining heavily this creates a
lot of noise meaning that the creatures
won't be able to hear human moments
anymore when H realizes this an idea
strikes his mind he leads his family
towards the cult members and launches a
brutal ambush from behind Hugh and the
Reverend then engage in a deadly tussle
which goes back and forth for a while
but in the end it is Hugh who gains the
upper hand and smashes the Reverend
using the rifle at the same time an
enraged Kelly also manages to kill the
rest of the cult members with the help
of Jude when the coast is finally clear
the Andrews are left face to face with
the girl who was strapped with mobile
phones earlier her mother is also
present probably a victim to the
Reverend Hugh stares at them for a while
and eventually lets them go knowing that
they are innocent the movie then cuts by
a few weeks the Andrews have since
relocated to another part of the country
which is now known as The Refuge many
call it the safest place in the United
States the movie ends as Ally reunites
with her love interest Rob and they
officially start dating